hey you guys do you like it here minimum  spell okay I'm ready do you remember the  last time we were on the couch the couch  hey guys do you remember the last time  we were seated on this couch doing  interviews for the making of camp Takota  this is how sex sessions let's make  another movie okay  we're throwing a house party movie and  you're invited to RSVP go to dirty  thirty movie.com  and check out all the behind the scenes  of the making of the film  sorry I only don't eat and drive and a  big THANK YOU to our friends over at  Lionsgate who most likely regret the  decision of working with us already but  too late it's already on the Internet